ciao ciao ospite disorientato posso
vederli prima della buona antenna dopo
18 anni di solito di ciao ragazzi
bentornati in una puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi è
quarantena come la state passando allora
in occasione di questa puntata purtroppo
non sono riuscito inizialmente a trovare
nessun tipo di ospiti non è possibile
incontrarsi con altre persone quindi
fondamentalmente quello che mi ero detto
è fine è per farlo da solo poi però mi
sono ricordato che in realtà esiste una
persona all'interno di questa casa oltre
il sottoscritto che mi sta tenendo un
sacco di compagnia durante questa
quarantena e che forse è giusto in
qualche modo farvi conoscere anche a voi
sto parlando lene coinquilina una
ragazza molto speciale e che stando al
piano di sopra ha deciso di non
presentarsi in carne ed ossa ma di
apparire tramite telefono per continuare
a promuovere soprattutto l'idea di stare
a distanza dagli altri quindi anche da
me in un certo senso
lasciate che bella presenti ciao ragazzi
è un piacere conoscerti vi sentite
guardate non vedo l'ora di fare la
nostra conoscenza di commentare quello
che vi sta succedendo nella vita insomma
quando pensavo che la quarantena non
potesse avere perso la vita mi stupisce
sempre da iniziamo non vedo l'ora
bando alle ciance la domanda che vi ho
fatto su facebook e su instagram è stata
una come state passando questa
quarantena e la domanda che fanno tutte
le persone che mi scrivono come sta
andando come non sta andando visto che
sei da solo
sto da solo sempre andiamo inquilina con
me è un pezzo di tornare perché sono
curioso ci sono storie positive storie
negative
scopriamo un pochino quali sono le
vostre accusate sto parlando a bassa
voce ma è la 143 bene un momento
migliore per mettersi a fare vi mando
niente che era la cera pescara
ciao se c'è ospite cia ospite da remoto
e io sono una ragazza di roma che con un
perfetto tempismo si è trasferita a
milano per lavoro novembre quando mi
sono trasferita ho deciso che non volevo
assolutamente nessuno in casa mi sono
presa una casa tutta per me quindi è in
questo momento questa cosa mi sembrava
un'idea molto sciocca all'inizio era
tutto fichissimo ora il giudizio ad
accusare i colpi sono comunque a una
persona molto fortunata perché fin dai
primi casi la mia azienda cia a tutti
messi subito in spark working quindi in
questo momento sono più usata fine
febbraio da sola in casa con me stessa e
basta i miei ormoni abbastanza difficile
questa situazione perché inizia ad
accusare cosa non mi ricordo manco più
come è fatto un pisello finito le canne
due settimane fa sto da sola quindi
niente peso ordinata un dildo su amazon
dio benedica i corrieri e basta quindi
il mio tempo libero l'impiego in
autoerotismo e alcol a palate questa è
la mia quarantena forza e coraggio a
tutti e dio benedica amazon questa che
lui sia quarantena di tutte le persone
che stanno passando questo periodo a
casa da soli sì non mi sento di
aggiungere altro voci della verità
immagino che tu stai bene finché anche
michael mann carino il mio racconto di
questi giorni l'italia sabato scorso
quando il mio ragazzo stava lavando i
piatti e se tagliate il dito in sostanza
quello che è successo è che ha perso
così tanto sangue che era svenuto ma
sopprimendo è scivolato cadendo con la
testa nel forno e per fortuna ce n'erano
accorti intento tesoro mai dato un'idea
se mi prometti che funziona questa volta
non solo dai piatti a guglielmo vicino
al sesso e motorio di torno che vuol
dire con la testa del forno che vuol
dire il sangue i ragazzi dovete stare
attenti in questo periodo è non vi
dovete far male perché non dovete andare
in ospedale per 200.000 motivi sia
perché sono pieni e server che è
veramente l'ultimo posto nel quale
andare in questo momento infatti grandi
medici
grandi palle grande vocazioni grandi
professionisti praticamente su 24 ore
ieri ho fatto conto sto 22 ore e 45
minuti eletto solo per mangiare e andare
in bagno ma no no no no no no no io ho
creato all'interno di casa mia una
piccola città io non ho mai vissuto così
tanto tutte le zone di casa mia non
italiano devo tantissimo il terrazzo ma
perché nel terrazzo messo il subwoofer
per poter fare il flash mob delle 18 per
me non sto facendo più perché oppure
mezzo lo dico io ma di base non a parte
no però forse casa tua solamente il
letto non nel senso che è uno spazio
molto piccolino no
in tal caso cioè piaghe da decubito
fisioterapia una volta che li prenderei
vivere lo sai come cachi in mano e la
lanci io durante per favore antena
dicevamo studiavano rinnovo studiavano
studiavo aperto un cassetto trapianti da
assetti di aver trovato molti tocchi di
quand'ero piccolo re spiderman scendere
accigliaro cambiato le pile mentre in
trappola di accenderle vedere se beccavo
qualche ripresa e niente appena
accettato per lui secondo beccato un
vecchio di 80 anni è praticamente parlò
questo vecchio quasi ogni pomeriggio è
stato strano vero
da un po di tempo e vabbè tanto il
signor filippo
salutiamo tutti quanti il signor filippo
delle sue parti io vado subito a fare
l'ordine metterò la ricerca di qualche
mi va bene anche la radio della polizia
che mi fanno l'elenco delle multe che
fanno chi esce fuori piango per le
vostre lettere innanzitutto su coutinho
gianmarco se mi è consentito cioè che ci
pensa sia lui a scegliere
svegliato ascoltare brava ad ogni modo
storia di un piano non poter sentire la
persona conquistò perché in realtà io
sono la sua mente in realtà facendo la
piantina con la ragazza ufficiale
trovano in questi termini è niente
quindi io sono costretta a mangiarmi di
vita un forse sarà la volta buona che
riesco ad uscirne
dov'è questa situazione abbastanza
inappropriata attivando per timo e stai
facendo tanta compagnia anche verso la
in questo momento quindi credo quindi
team hanno fortemente grazie grazie
mille grazie per questo complimento me
lo prendo e me lo porto a casa
in realtà devo essere sincero funziona
anche al contrario a me sta facendo
tanta compagnia tutto questo se non ci
fosse stato tutto questo è che fosse
rimasto solo primi pensieri
ecco non avrei tirato fuori a conquilina
avere tirato fuori un intero presepe
quindi che a me non è mai capitato di
trovarmi a fare amante cose così
quindi non so sinceramente che dirti
tesoro entra in gioco io tranquilla
allora non il tema state le scelte degli
altri non sono una torta che dopo 40
minuti per mangiare se le persone solo
una torta in forno e dopo 40 minuti
della pro mangiare e cosa fai russi più
durante questa cosa intendono i primi 22
giorni non ha fatto carne che alle 18
seguire fisico da noi 17
avere tre lezioni online fisico da colin
dalle 17 e restare così fino a giugno da
paura allora questa è una cosa molto
bella in realtà fisica capitolo stiamo
provando in tutti i modi è una live che
faccio con mio fratello cabrini enrico
lui di sabato alle 17 nella quale ci
alleniamo io ragazzi sto tirando che il
piano fuori un fisico da cota
basta seguirla per capire che cosa
stiamo parlando è un periodo del quale
anch'io sto tirando fuori un sacco di
progetti creatività e cose così uniti
out sia totale in realtà devo dire che
sto bene e più delle volte è che andando
avanti migliora migliora sempre di più
solamente mangio totale delle impedita
dei piedi scherzo mi sto ritrovando
molto cioè mi sento un sacco me non so
come dire una è una sensazione strana mi
sento io speriamo duri anche quando
finirà se finirà trovo e fa orbita in
caso finanziario dell'inizio della
quarantena una compagna che fino ad ora
non è ancora abbandonato una pistola
sacro coccigea cioè in pratica un enorme
brufolo che no di pd e post che non mi
permette di stare sdraiata con la
schiena controllate rassomigli male
stare seduta l'unica attività che avrei
potuto fare per passare la quarantenne
modo produttivo e stare al computer a
scrivere la tesi e ci riesci a un po ma
poi scrivi tipo sdraiata la fine dei
vicini nella schiena te per farle
cavallo c'è un po vorrei tipo vedere il
dottor po perché le spreme queste cose
però dall'altra parte braccia certo
senso lo so ma gira il male se il regime
non sederti un esplode come funziona non
mi parlare di brufoli pieni di pulse e
lione uno che gira per casa dall insomma
quarantena magari un giorno di questi
cade dalle scale
finisce con la testa del forno come
ragazzo di quell'altra sono io chiudo è
imposto il timer
ciao sono qui per
raccontarti la parte bella della
quarantena diciamo perché da quando sono
rimasta bloccata tra virgolette il mio
moroso che comunque già con vivevamo in
una ci vediamo tutti i giorni tramite
videochiamata e questa distanza perché
alla fine ormai sono tre settimane che
non ci vediamo cia unite in una maniera
allucinante
penso di aver capito mia mamma più in
queste tre settimane di lontananza che
in vent'anni di vita e non vedo per
ritornare poterlo abbracciare stringere
forte chiederle scusa per tutte le volte
che sono stata una figlia insopportabile
cosa molto bella da dire se non è una
mamma un addio generare una persona che
cosa carina che ha detto iet una cosa
carinissima non voglio commentarle
nessun altro modo veramente ascoltare
queste frasi lasciarli per mettere la
mia testa fatto ci sta a scusare ciao
gufi share noi amo tantissimo io ho
fatto una stagione in montagna da
animatrice e sono tornata al giorno da
pollo proclamato l'italia zona rossa
quindi non vedevo da rivedere i miei
amici e si è chiusa in casa con rapaci
cassa cosa comunque qui stiamo toccando
dei livelli di pazzia estremi in casa io
mio fratello e mia madre non sappiamo
assolutamente che cosa fare mio fratello
studia quello che è da gelato di più
nella pazzia perché è abituato a uscire
per assegnare in biblioteca passa la
giornata a fare versa di questo tipo
noi non sappiamo
pare che quando questo passo ma si è
interrotta così la tia credito 8
fratello un cane pensi che il tuo
labrador sia un essere umano
no no no ciao intanto volevo dirti che
tu sei assolutissimamente parte attiva
della mia quarantena e che senza gli
appuntamenti con un fisico da cofide con
le due storici di instagram tutto quanto
avrebbe avuto un altro sapore a graziolì
vengo da roma ma mi trovo a vienna in
questo momento e abito in uno studentato
quindi da quando qui hanno chiuso
l'università praticamente il palazzo in
cui abito è completamente vuoto se non
per altri quattro ragazzi italiani che
non hanno fatto in tempo come me farà
entrare a casa prima vigili essere
confini quello che facciamo per
intrattenerci avendo un intero
condominio a nostra disposizione è
giocare a guardie e ladri che figata
giorni fa ha organizzato una caccia al
tesoro
noi abbiamo la lavanderia in comune io
ho nascosto la chiave dalla lavanderia
fino a quando non risolvono tutti i
nominati nessuno può lavarsi fanghi tra
neve e cioè giochiamo sono due giorni
che cercano genio stupendo io mi sto
dando al pianoforte in questa 40 in atto
componendo più pet ceo di mogol orribili
ma li sto componendo di fare sentire
qualcosa ma è veramente tardi ora sono
le 2 11 come la sento la mia storia non
è una storia per la quarantena con
marito e un figlio di 5 anni 1 v1 è non
riuscire a [ __ ] neanche per sbaglio
meno già prima che ti capisco
perfettamente perché questa qui ora la
sesta società ad ancona nemica questa
mia amica praticamente vorrebbe stuprare
il ragazzo ma hanno un ospite a casa e
quindi no ogni giorno che la vedo io
vedo la sua psiche e sempre più sfaldata
un paio di giorni fa io ho chiamato
questo mio amico e gli ho detto ti
supplico ti supplico ti scongiuro
chiamatela ti prego fallo per me va bene
una sparachiodi anche ragazzi ragazze se
state insieme alla vostra dolce metà
trovate spostate mi commuovo trovate
trovate il tempo
pensate a noi pensate a noi e quindi
fatelo anche per noi
ma proprio a costo di farlo senza voglia
fatelo perché veramente chi ha il pane
non ha i denti e [ __ ] voi e molti
giorni di reclusione forzata
vabbè parte che non vedo il mio
fidanzato e non mangio se uscire o esce
per sé abbastanza bene l'unico guaio
delle persone attorno a me come anche i
familiari amici che cazzeggiano vanno
dai parenti si vanno a fare le
scampagnate e per colpa non ostacola
terra non finirà mai chiusa questo mi
sono riesce abbastanza energies co
allora vi susciti capisco vorrei fare un
appello a tutte queste persone
cercherò di essere il più diplomatico
possibile test rica faccia di minchia
non siete altro
so che avete la me è la testa e che
molto probabilmente le scoraggiano i
pensieri ogni volta che cercare di
formularne uno
sappiate che se l'utile fossimo stati
tutti quanti a casa dal giorno zero noi
in due settimane avremo praticamente
risolto tutto ho un po di più e invece
sapete perché se si continua a
contagiare le teste di capcom e voi che
spero che vengano prese da una pioggia
di merli ma di quella dura dura e con un
cuore fondente che faccia male ma che
poi gli abbracci di permei razionale
difficile rimanere a casa
io lo so che sarebbe bello uscire lo so
se dei [ __ ]
devo dire la mia allora io ho avviato
così che ogni volta che vedo una persona
a camminare strada fare jogging quelle
cose lì e io le sparo ho comprato una
carabina al mercato nero allora risalire
che in questa volante la mia madre si
sta andando alla pazza gioia quelle voi
siete casa ok la mattina mi sveglio alla
buon'ora vado in saloni cerco mamma
faccio mamma che sento la sua voce fa
sono qui da cercola cerco e dove me la
trovo sopra l'armadio che saranno
quattro metri armadio o la scala che era
intento a pulire sopra la neve è preso
un colpo
ma nel senso che tua mamma era salita
sopra l'armadio la scala era vuota e tu
madre stava tipo gufo eccomi qui miliani
e io pure dovrà pulire un po di più a
casa mia ma non c'ho voglia
non essere così duro con il livello di
igiene di questa dimora io ho solamente
presso la sifilide una terza volta
dall'inizio della quarantena ovviamente
e niente ho sviluppato delle allergie a
patogeni che non pensavo nemmeno
esistessero su questa terra ed è bene
comunque camminare per caso perché io
cammino sempre con le scarpe sento il
brecciolino che scricchiola sotto i
piedi che mi da quell'idea di trekking
in montagna oggi sono ritenuti
carabinieri della mia vicina che hanno
portato a casa con l'amante perché
l'hanno trovata arco in macchina e lei
non era detto al marito che andava a
fare da badante per due giorni stava col
suo amante
praticamente i carabinieri sono arrivati
a casa come in macchina lei e la madre
in un sidecar idea tutti i vicini hanno
sentito tutto l'emozione più grande di
questa quarantena c'è un dico che è
stato meraviglioso perché mi dispiace
per il mio vicino perché le persone
meravigliose certo non potevo non
ascoltare quando la realtà supera
l'immaginazione
wow questo è uno degli aneddoti che
davanti a un momento di difficoltà ci
dovrebbe far pensare a casa vicino di
quella sono privilegiato sono un cavolo
di privilegiato ciao ciao ospite che ci
sia
leggo ogni giorno sui sei ram su
facebook ei vari social perché la gente
si annoia causa vuole andare al lavoro
vuole uscire ma so che l'unica che mi
piace un sacco stare a casa
la cosa più bella che mi sia concessa in
24 anni di vita mi dispiace ovviamente
progetto che quelle persone che stanno
male certo ma il mistero e andò in
quarantena so salvando il mondo in
pigiama in ciabatte mangia indebolendo
fin tutto il giorno e tra l'altro hanno
anche pagato di più ciao e buona
quarantena tutte grazie anche a tre
composto passando invece a me quello che
manca il contatto umano c'è proprio
quello che mi faceva stare bene
sicuramente o filtrato tutto quello lì
che non mi serviva oche che mi spegnerà
per hbo un po che pur se mancano ciao
duccio ospite virtuale spero che tu ci
sia vorrei chiedere la vostra opinione
riguardo a ricontattare un ex in questo
periodo addirittura nei sei certo
ricontattare un ex
allora io ho una teoria che è la teoria
del check point sharepoint sarebbero i
punti di salvataggio nei videogiochi nei
quali se tu muori ricominci da quel
punto che non è proprio l'inizio di
inizio a volte nelle relazioni succede
che almeno il successo hammer di
trovarmi in situazioni di difficoltà e
quindi di ricominciare dall'ultimo
checkpoint che magari è una persona con
la quale sono stato bene ho della quale
ho filtrato tutti gli aspetti negativi
perché bene o male io ho sempre dei
bellissimi ricordi tutte quante le
persone alle quali sono stato anche se
in realtà ci sono stati problemi
altrimenti la maggior parte di queste
non sarebbero finite
no chiediti se è un modo per superare la
quarantena o se la quarantena che ti ha
permesso di superarsi da casa la capri
cannes e che secondo me ha un senso
implicito molto importante io però sono
dell'idea che più delle volte
fatemi sapere se per voi diverso è tanto
difficile che la minestra riscaldata sia
buona conta prima volta in cui è
lanciata le persone per potersi
ritrovare dovrebbero essere cambiate
moltissimo e allo stesso tempo non
essere cambiato affatto so che sto
facendo discorsi del cavolo però è vero
dovresti provare la stessa attrazione
che magari provato in passato è riuscito
aggiustare quelle cose che addirittura
hanno fermato e bloccato una relazione è
uno di quei pareri che dovresti chiedere
a persone che ti hanno conosciuto che vi
hanno conosciute e soprattutto a te
stesso
restava giallo perché lo vuoi lo sta
facendo perché hai bisogno
tesoro io proprio fatto come te preso la
rubrica ha ricontattato tutti gli ex
tipo figurine panini video collezionati
tutti le collezioni di tutti tutti
quanti la cosa vuol dire facevo le foto
una volta le mandavo a tutti quanti e
alla fine di tutto ciò che posso dire
che stavo meglio sola meglio comunque
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questa puntata sono le tue e mezza e
tardissimo andare a dormire
quell io devo fare niente quindi non
dover a dormire però spero che questa
puntata vi sia piaciuta ringrazio ancora
la mia coinquilina per aver preso parte
a questo video ciao guglielmo grazie a
te mi raccomando non azzardare ma è più
cancello il mio numero basso chissà a
tutti è stato un piacere nel bello come
sempre vi invito a scrivervi a questo
canale invito a mettermi un pollice in
su per il anche 23 anche 20 a 40 era si
fa sentire e soprattutto fatemi sapere
qua sotto come state passando questo
periodo di isolamento stata rossi gas
ritrovando voi stessi state solista in
compagnia litigate quando le remore
d'accordo ci sono delle cose che non mi
piace come sta avvenendo gestite potevo
sapere più allora vi mando un bacio ci
vediamo domenica con una nuova puntata
di cucina buttata ciao